and so I wanted to just start community
boss there selfishly for myself that I
would have a place to go making sure you
are moving forward and not backwards
that we focused on one thing at a time
what are some of the key things that
prevent people from building that for
six figures in their company and there
she is
hello Natalie Elizabeth Ellis in the
house founder of the boss babe movement
how you doing I'm good like Spanish
music it was amazing but not so much for
9 a.m. so I met I met Natalie in Puerto
Rico about a couple months ago just
before January and we were at Brendan
bouchard's mastermind event I guess his
private mastermind event that was that
was a ton of fun and I loved the mission
that she's on and building her boss babe
community so for people who aren't as
familiar with boss babe and what you're
doing what what have you built so it
started out as an Instagram account four
or five years ago and slowly just built
into this incredible business we now
have all the 15 million uses of our
hashtag boss babe we have a membership
courses we have physical products we
have licensing so it's really just
turned into this incredible community
and platform where we say where women
can just be unapologetically ambitious
where we will help them get those
resources those connections that they
need to build their empires and I
noticed you have your new line of
clothing out with Elle as well yeah very
exciting
aren't you in quarantine and we have to
create our own photoshoot which is
actually happening again today so we're
just making it work I love it so I want
your website and on the homepage is
talking about how to build you know your
first hundred thousand other business
what are some of the key things that
that you feel prevent people from
building that
for six figures in their company so two
things the first thing just getting
started honestly and really slowly going
all in and committing I see a lot of
people kind of half in half out with
that businesses where they haven't
really made that decision they've got
something else on the side and they're
trying it out but it's not like burn the
books it's not going all-in so that's
the first thing and the second thing
that I see a lot is people not
prioritizing sales not Peres sizing
revenue and instead you know if you're a
VC packed company that's fine but if you
are so look funded and you're growing
organically you know prioritizing
systems and prioritizing design and all
of those nice-to-haves I think can
really hold people back and they're
constantly investing trying to get
things perfect before they then go out
and make money whereas I think in the
beginning stages really when you're
growing to your first Exchequer's it's
all up through then your concept and
proving that you have a product and
offer that people actually want and it's
gonna take time to get it right and to
get it right you need paying customers
in the door and so I really recommend
when people are in that stage just go
all in with that revenue vision and
thinking about how you are going to
sustain income system Rev and use that
you kind make it a full-time thing to
kind of go all-in and when you hit that
six-figure mark and you've generally got
that consistent 8k and be struggling you
coming in and month gives you a lot of
freedom to play with where you can then
go back and design the logo and go back
and do those nice things but in the
beginning it's not super important how
did you transition because I think is a
super interesting for people from just
have an Instagram account and posting
content and inspirational and you know
you're storing all that to then building
a real business and building a real
movement and and it's happened yes over
a period of years but it's still
relatively quickly so how did you make
that transition from just being people
could look at you and say oh she's just
an influencer talking to women
entrepreneurs to now building a sizable
business as a result of it yes it was
actually my second business and for me
but it was something on the side that I
was doing so I had a product based
business where I was manufacturing
supplements we were in stores across the
UK shipping
60 countries and it was great but it had
so many cash flow issues because the
physical product it cost so much to
manufacture but I always be bringing the
money in first and one I remember one
day I was like I'm gonna create a recipe
put it up on that website and that'll
help me bring more cash flow in so I'm
not having to constantly invest and so I
did that and they've seen the power of e
products because I started making all of
these sales I have nothing to ship
I had to map all of these big overhead I
was like this is really interesting so
there was that part of the business that
starts opening up to this industry
because I had no idea that people could
sell information I just wasn't aware of
it and then on the other side I was
growing this Instagram account that was
really really taken off and a lot of
people were asking for that and I
remember the biggest thing I was facing
was it was just go lonely I didn't
really have anyone to turn to while I
was trying to figure out you know how to
pay for these invoices how to bring in
investors and loans and all of these
different things that was just no one
talking about that and so I wanted to
just start community or boss there
selfishly for myself so that I would
have a place to go and so we just
started really small as a small
membership and it started to grow really
quickly and if we're not that point I
was like I don't want to do this on my
own like this is you know we had a lot
of followers we moved on to make a lot
of revenue I didn't want to do it on my
own
and so I met Danielle at a Brendan
Rashad event which is so amazing a few
years ago and we just clicked right away
and she had her own business sometimes
she had a brick-and-mortar business
she's chiropractor and we decided to
come together and use all of our skills
so I think our backgrounds of being
employed in brick-and-mortar then moving
online really helped because we were
able to see issue that we might come up
against him once we decided to come
together we just did that for burn the
boat ride you were like this as the
business we're going to go all-in on and
then from there it was really about
educating our whole audience so instead
of just being a page or an influencer we
start to read we educate them as to who
we are what we stand for what they can
expect and really condition them to
expect paid content from us so it's not
going to be constant free content and
yeah
it's gonna be a sell at the end and we
were just really unapologetic about that
and the reception we got was amazing our
audience what obviously craving it and
since then we've just very much listened
to what they want and in that direction
so so-called we created a planner we
created everything's being very much
dank telling us for so long can you
please do it and it's fine you mean like
that we'll do it and so that's how the
business is really developed now what
was the first thing that you started to
sell was it the membership mm-hmm the
membership was first it was we right now
had a membership called the Society it
actually wasn't the Society it was a
whole different when I was a cheaper $10
a month membership then we opted at $84
a month membership and then we grew to
multiple save some figures just with
that then we create a course and so we
did things very slowly we didn't have
multiple products we had one part that
was scaled and then we had a course that
we scales and then we started to bring
in brands to where points because we had
such a big audience with buying power
which is quite unique so we started to
bring in brand partnerships and and
other things like that so we've just
gone really it looks like it's been
quick but it's been very slow in that
we've focused on one thing at a time and
the planner just came out and late last
year that was something that's been
asked for for years and we just knew if
we take our focus off of what we're
doing right now we can't keep scaling so
feel very slow like there's a million
and one things that I want to be doing
but I do want to really scale properly
and without little bugs I'm really not
available for that it hasn't been slower
what's the difference between your
planner and and Brendan's
high-performance planner it's smaller
for sure it's a lot easier to put in
your handbag and then it's just
different so Brendan's really focused on
high performance and reviewing
holistically cause it's pretty just
pretty much just focused on what you're
gonna achieve so you have a 90 day
sprint it's very business focused and
then focusing on what you've been
achieve in your business each day so a
quite different is it is it morning and
evening or once a day or what's the
system I'll show you actually have one
all right there we go here we go so it's
smaller
I love it you have a 90 day sprint where
we we almost do this I actually got this
idea originally contraction just doing
90 days at time and then every day you
come in you do three Grateful three
gratitudes but you do them preemptively
so it's things like you haven't really
got yet so I want to sign 10 clients
today or I want to make X amount of
money today you put them in the grad
shoes as if it's happened so I am so
grateful that I watch them through York
lines today then you do three top balls
and then you lift stagnant reduce you
take them off and then that's it and
there's like a little system in Y it's
done delayed delegate delete but three
simple it's just a few things every day
and then also there's a notebook page
because one thing that we were really
struggling with was having to fit
planning our notebooks into our bags at
the same time that's really heavy and we
would want goals because the planet
isn't a good notebook so we're really
happy that's the first thing and then
secondly you'd be in a meeting because I
still look to write paper I know
especially if I'm going to different
people's offices you'd be you'd write
notes down and then you come to find
them again you can't see them and so
with the planner so you had a meeting
last Thursday you open it up with a
notebook as well so you can see what
else you wrote last Thursday so it
really was all about the handbag
initially we were like how do we just
create something that just is really
easy and actually effective because
sometimes they're really cute girly
planners are not so effective so right
so how do you decide what the next 90
days sprint should be so for us when we
begin to set the beginning of the year
we I love paper because we get a massive
like whiteboard or shoot payback we
divide it into four quarters and we just
start to brainstorm what are the big
things we want to be achieving in that
month so is it a big event is it a
product launch what does that look like
and we start just put that in the
different quadrants and we'll step back
and take a look and see if this getting
us where we want to be in three years is
this gonna really help us move the
needle if so we start to put different
dates on that because what can often
happen is the beginning of the year you
have all of these grand ideas I've I'm
gonna launch all these products I'm
gonna do these different things wire is
what you see it right in front of
you realize there is no way I'm gonna
get all of those things done like I
remember when I first started I was like
I'm gonna create an app I'm gonna
redesign the bug seven a launch product
all in q1 it's just not gonna happen
and so we would start to map it out like
that and make sure we were not trying to
do too many things at once and then we
just leave it there we didn't go into
granular detail of each cortello
beginning of each quartet we go through
the traction exercise where you think
about like what are the big milestones
you want to work towards so it might be
launching a product and then what are
the the clinical rocks underneath that
so one of the rocks that are gonna help
you get there
so the needle moving activities that
take more than two weeks we write down
the rocks and we find owners for them so
one thing that's been really
instrumental for a scaling is making
sure that all of these rocks or
milestones have owners and those owners
on your Danielle because we can become
bottlenecks and if we're to if what you
attack like involved in all of these
different things we can't pull out and
actually scale and grow and you think
about q2 q3 q4
so we make sure they they have owners
and then we host a meeting with our team
and we walk through all of that and we
try and make it pretty collaborative as
well because they have ideas that we
haven't even thought about so building a
teams being the readiest remember one
actually being able to plan in this way
if you're at the beginning and you may
not I mean things change so much at the
very beginning of a business how would
you recommend like what if you're
halfway through 90-day sprints and then
realize oh I don't actually want to be
doing this I found something else do you
just stick it out cuz you said 90 days
do you pivot what what's your
recommendation for people I would I
think in the beginning stage of the
business sometimes you're really led by
opportunity in that you've set out in
the next 90 days I'm gonna achieve XYZ
but then like certain opportunities to
come your way you're like that actually
would really help me get some that and
that feels really aligned or a Caillou
wanted to come work with you even though
you didn't ever think you want to work
with this kind of person but the offer
they make use like wow I actually think
I will enjoy that and so I think at the
beginning it's all about giving us our
space to greet but making sure you're
moving forward and not backwards so not
about in you know 30 days they're like
this is a lot of work
are you wanting to pivot because it's
you know you want to give up you want to
go backwards or are you pimp see because
something's come along there actually
it's gonna give you a leap in your
business because in the beginning I
remember for me nothing was so
structured it was very much just I was
focused on putting one foot in front of
the other and I did I had these visions
but I didn't really know how I was gonna
get that I didn't know what my master
plan was and I think that really saved
me because I was willing to just not
know what I didn't know I think that's
really important so I would say if
you're really early-stage you know just
like figuring out how you're gonna get
that regular income but your care with
pivoting and be okay with change and
just have those big non-negotiables up
there when maybe that's your revenue
goals maybe that's making traction in a
certain way and the rest of it you're
open to figuring out so do you still do
you recommend still doing a 90 day plan
and just be one of the pivot or do you
just say I don't know you have your
goals and be open to opportunity I like
having a plan I think that really does
work I would really recommend setting
safe three things that you really want
to achieve like three big goals that you
want to achieve in 90 days and then
think about maybe two rocks underneath
each one of those so maybe one of the
goals is launch a new course the two
rocks under that is create the content
for it and like put it like build a
platform whatever that looks like or
another big goal is hit educate in
revenue or any search it tanked in
revenue and then how you're gonna do
that map that out I just have three top
level goals and that's a plan that in
itself is a plan because one of the
biggest things I see really trip people
up is they wake up not knowing what to
do in their business so they wake up
feeling lost
they don't have clarity we don't have
directions and that is I know and I will
say like being in the early stages of
your business is often one of the
hardest stages because you're not really
getting that instant gratification for
things you're doing you might be laying
on the ground with but you're not seeing
the revenue you're not seeing the
clients and not having that instant
ratifications really difficult and if
you're waking up and you're not really
sure what to work on you'll end up
crass naming so then you'll tell
yourself you're not good enough you have
all of this negative self-talk send
you're gonna wake up not feeling
motivated and it really is this loop
tell me in the comments if you can
relate to this move because I feel like
a lot of people plan on your iPad let us
know and so I think having a plan can
get you out of that because you wake up
and you know what you're working towards
and so even if you just do one thing a
day that's helping you move slowly
towards that things and that's a win
what do you think is unique to women
entrepreneurs boss babe entrepreneurs
that men either don't go through or just
is different mmm I think for women
entrepreneurs I know men go through this
but I think it's more amplified with
women it's confidence a lot of women
really struggle with the confidence to
go out there and create their own
businesses and I see that way more
female entrepreneurs and I see in this
which is crazy I'm seeing a lot of gaps
I've lake I really that's a big thing
and that's been one of the number one
things that we've worked on with the
women in our community is laying that
foundation or even Newcastle no but I'm
from Newcastle and I'm really impressed
that that person knows that from my
accent so that's a big thing and then
the second thing I would say and it's
actually probably right now but I see I
don't personally have children but I see
a lot of women who have maybe been
stay-at-home mums or of maybe you know
not had a career in a while that I'm
wanting to start businesses and they
have a lot to juggle and they are doing
a lot of that I see that a lot and so a
lot of the clients I work with will be
mums and they will say to me I have
three hours a day to get this done
because I've got all this other stuff to
do in between and their husbands are at
work and they're the ones looking after
kids and I see that a lot so I think
that's also a big challenge but I know
men also do have to deal with that
because those roles are changing I have
children running three businesses yeah
it's it's definitely something that I
would say those two things are confident
and that balance element and I don't
love to talk about moms because I hate
my women get us how do you balance it
all so stereotypical and its really true
our balancing a lot and I know those
rules are changing which I'm really
really pleased about but it is a lot and
I think about when I want to have kids
in a couple of years time my life needs
to look really different I need to put
those things in place my husband isn't
thinking about that stuff I know fine
well he isn't and he's just happy
running his business and when kids come
along you'd be like wow we got kids for
me
I have to really think about that how do
I run a business while I'm pregnant how
do I run a business when I'm
breastfeeding how do I do all those
things and so I'm constantly like that's
in my mind so I want to have kids in the
next couple of years and so I just it's
different so step one what would it give
a you know mom entrepreneur or future
boss babe who wants to start a business
doesn't have a lot of time is lacking in
self-confidence what step one to
building the confidence to believe that
they could actually do this so I think
one thing that really helps build
confidence especially in Korea is
following through what you're gonna do
because if you tell yourself you're
gonna workout twice a week and you never
work out
at the end of the weekend you look back
and be like I failed with this I'm just
not good at it and when you break
promises yourself consistently that
self-talk really comes in and you're
essentially proven to yourself that
you're not consistent and you're not
keeping up with what your promises are
so I think the first step is really
being really having to follow through
with what you say you're gonna do that's
a really big thing and secondly I think
doing the foundational work of like we
all have personal bond what to do we all
have these like limiting beliefs that
I'm not good enough and I'm not where we
all have we all
and I think entrepreneurship is those
big right of self development like it
will really your business will show you
who you are and what your limiting
beliefs are and the earlier you can
address those the better I've worked
with a lot of women that have had
certain beliefs around money and just
haven't even know one that they had
those beliefs in were completely getting
in their own way with procrastination
and everything and I always say that
procrastination really is if your
thought there's something else in your
subconscious that is stopping you from
getting that done so go do the work go
do some personal development where you
there are so many thought leaders online
Brendon being one of them there are a
lot of people online that i helping you
dive into that that personal development
work reading books on it so being
willing to take a real hard look at
yourself and it sets of what it is
that's gonna keep you stuck i love it
now now part of my mission has become to
get natalie on youtube i'm doing it are
you yeah are you making content i was on
today okay okay yes I'm filming corner
of my house and the content ship
kickoffs filming in two weeks and I'm
probably gonna film for a couple of
weeks uh car enough and it's gonna be
weekly doing it I love it now what is it
is it coaching is it is it just talking
to the camera or what yeah so it's gonna
be kind of a mix so in the beginning I'm
gonna do a series on how to grow
Instagram because partly that's really
good content to grow with it so I'm
gonna do a series around that so I'll be
doing some talking to come round I'll be
doing some why I'm sharing my screen it
just showing how to do certain things um
and that's kind of as far as I've got
I've got my next eight videos planned
out so I might Tucker on the shoulder
and ask if I'm doing it the right way
happy - I'm happy I'm doing it are you
really convinced me one of the things I
struggle with the most is fighting with
my team to get more women entrepreneur
content on the channel
because there's not enough I think it's
back to the conference issue there's not
enough women making long-form YouTube
content who will have had success as an
entrepreneur right there's a few but not
not a lot of consistent if you start
with Instagram and you did like an eight
part series like part one is this and
part two is this and part three that all
leads to each other and then you end
with with one or two coaching sessions
of taking some of your students and then
coaching them live on there or like a
zoom call yeah yeah do a breakdown
because it's either they pay to get it
or it's just like hey thank you so much
for being a part of our community
you get to get 15 minutes with Natalie
to break down your Instagram and then
that becomes a video of again just
showing how great you are but also like
massive value right so it's not just
your account it's live coach on it would
take off and that's back to your roots
like your original videos on YouTube I'm
happy to help get it off the ground
amazing yes because I know all the
challenges that I'm facing doing it one
of them being the tech I the tech has
been syllable warming to me but I'm
getting there and I really wanted to
learn it myself and like all of that and
so I'm gonna be teaching all of that
that probably that'll become some my
videos but I think you're totally right
I need to be more women on there but it
can be so overwhelming to get started it
sounds easy you spy opponents are
talking yeah yeah but and even the I
would I would lower the production
quality because the quality is really
your ideas what's in your head that's a
quality morning
more than how fancy the images are or
anything else and especially the code I
like you would just crush the coaching
of bring a woman on do a do a zoom call
together have her tell you her problems
help her with her Instagram and there's
also you're gonna just naturally infuse
personal element inside of it
like the reason why she's not post on
interview ones because she doesn't have
enough confidence and you're gonna help
her through that like it's just you're
crushing your crush yeah as long as the
internet connections decent you can do
even even this like right now Gary Vee
and a bunch of people are just taking
Instagram live videos and we're like
this and they just rotate it to be like
this and like cutting in half and post
it as a video oh my god because it's
still the quality of the knowledge more
than the editing right if you are a
video editor and that was your business
then yeah a thousand percent but you're
teaching people how to to get what's out
of your head into theirs that's the most
important thing yeah I love it alright
cool well it's crazy
how quickly time flies I'm pumped for
the YouTube channel but if people
watching they want to learn more about
you dive into your world where do you
want them to go next so they can follow
us
americana McNall Buster dink or my
personal account at I am Natalie I love
it Natalie thank you so much of the time
I'll talk to you soon thank you
all right take care if you want to see
the one on one I did with another
amazing woman entrepreneur Lisa bill you
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there